much their nutrition is of course a
really critical component of the week
and I would imagine the players have set
routines that they go through in that
period yeah so probably the best example
is at 3 o'clock kickoff that's pretty
standard for a weekend pretty much meal
perfect something to be a large bowl of
pasta after that it's pretty much get on
the bus on the way to the game there'll
be some carbohydrate sport drinks
they'll be some electrolytes tablets to
add sir waters to top-up their
electrolytes and keep them thirsty and
then when they get to the ground
they all have their individual routine
whether it's a little bar or a sports
drink or gel during the game the players
are all told to take maximum
opportunities at the breaks in play and
the whole team's on that so right now
for physio anyone that runs onto the
pitch to give treatment they've always
got drinks available to them halftime
the players get straight on to their
individualized personal strategies that
top up of a carbohydrate gel topping up
their electrolytes and rehydration
players that like to take some extra
caffeine for the second half second half
same thing take up on the jitters breaks
in play we have our players who you'll
consistently use the cramping games they
would just feel fatigued towards the end
of games you know the carbohydrate
sources are crucial to them over the
course of 90 minutes there's still
opportunities for the players to take
onboard carbohydrates in the form of
gels you know and also sports drinks
just to give them that little bit more
subtle carbohydrates which will help
them through to the end of the game and
then games one when we're back in the
changing room and the recovery strategy
start the its carbohydrate and protein
based recovery shakes driving that sore
muscle glycogen top-up looking towards
that next game
[Music]